if you're looking for ways to always be
yourself create great experiences and do
what you love then this video is for you
when I am at work it's never like I'm
looking at my clock think you know gee
another hour and I get to go home it's
more like I should have gone home two
hours ago I do not have a TV character I
do not have a Twitter character I do not
have a sneaky writer perspective I only
bring to the table what I have I mean
remember when we opened Baba there was
no internet and there was no cell phones
and I was perplexed that they could ever
be any help to us what's that belief
nation it's Evan my one word is
believing I believe in you I believe you
have an amazing gift inside you that I
want to see explode out into the world
so let's get your motivation to a 10 and
get you believing in you grab a snack
and chew in today's lessons from a man
who went from being a cook at a college
pub called stuff your face to having his
own TV shows and owning restaurants
around the world he's Muriel Batali and
here's my take on his top ten rules of
success enjoy
let's kick things off with rule number
one never be satisfied to be or to think
that you have become everything that is
ever gonna be done in one particular
place it's generally either a symptom of
blindness foolishness or laziness I
think it's crucial to realize that at
any level you might sometime you need to
change some portion of what you're doing
I would say we're still in the middle of
the development of La Serena it started
out as a like 500 seat restaurant which
we're not really good at running so we
haven't yet succeeded
I mean we're popular and it's making
profit and a lot of people come here but
I'm not completely satisfied with our
product or our offering to this day and
I would say that that goes with most of
my restaurants if you're ever completely
done and completely satisfied with
something well then you're not in my
business up next is rule number two do
what you love for those of us who are
interested in pursuing careers in the
culinary industry what is your best
piece of advice and how we can go about
achieving that it depends are you
interested in the restaurant industry or
the overall food world sure okay well
good then then study anything that makes
you feel good right now and be an A
student and when you're done go work in
something that seems like where you'd
like to be for free for six months
anybody will take someone who has
insurance for six months for free to
test-drive it
the uninsured however become an issue
because there's a lot of people out
there that aren't and there's a whole
mess of litigious skanks out there who
would love to sue us for letting someone
work for our restaurant for free so what
you need to do is figure out whether
it's a magazine or whether it's a
dietician facility or whether it's
sports medicine or what I mean there's a
thousand ways to get involved in the
field find one that you think is the one
that you'd likely enjoy the most because
I can tell you one thing of all of my
college roommates
perhaps Greg Ostroff and I have nailed
it the best in that when I am at work
it's never like I'm looking at my clock
think you know gee another hour and I
get to go home it's more like I should
have gone home two hours ago because I
never go to work a day in my life when
you love what you do you're never at
work you are always enjoying it it's
kind of like being in college except
they pay us so find something that you
like and then dally in it like spend the
next summer if you want to be at food
wine magazine and you write Dana Cowin
Arcade crater and say Mario Batali said
I could call you and I can come work in
your place for free they'll say yes are
you insured and you'll say yes I am I'm
happy to come in on my own time I just
want to be a fly on the wall or I want
to help you guys do something and in a
restaurant and a magazine in in a soup
kitchen in a food service facility like
at a college here or a grease truck or
any one of the places they'll always
take on free labor and you will learn a
lot about that experience and you'll
also learn a lot about your potential
for happiness doing that and that's most
importantly what you really have to do
is say can I see myself doing this for
30 years and I don't think there's any
of us I mean I didn't think I could do
anything for 30 years and I'm old look
I'm still doing it let's move to rule
number three satisfy your staff and
customers if you in your mind decided
that your
it's gonna be about feeding people you
have to understand that there's one
piece of that which is feeding people
the other piece of that and there's
three is that you're taking care of your
family of staff in a way that allows
them to feel as important in your world
as is serving the customer 20 years ago
I spent a hundred percent of my time on
their guests satisfaction now I spend 50
percent of my time on guest satisfaction
and 50 percent of my time on staff
satisfaction because at the end of the
day you're only as good as your team is
and if they are not happy or if they're
eventually just moving on quickly
because they're trying to build their
own little resume and go work for Gordon
Ramsay and then go work for Daniel below
and then go work for Mario Batali and
then do this and all of a sudden like
they're just like spinning what you
really need to be is someone who totally
gets both the integration of your staff
happiness and your customer happiness
when you understand that
you can start a restaurant time for rule
number four always be yourself I wish
there was a wall to my private stuff the
beauty and the trouble with me is that I
wear my heart on my sleeve and I am only
one guy I do not have a TV character I
do not have a Twitter character I do not
have a sneaky writer perspective I only
bring to the table what I am and it's
unedited version that people find the
real me let's go to rule number 5 create
great experiences there's a lot of
investments going into the idea of
changing the whole way restaurants are
done I was in an airport the other day
everything's on an iPad they bring it to
you what do you think like that or do
you feel that there's not gonna be a
shift in how restaurants our restaurants
just be restaurants for and I mean I am
I used to I mean remember when we opened
Baba there was no internet and there was
no cellphones and I was perplexed that
they could ever be any help to us so
anything could change and I'm not
opposed to the idea of that but what our
restaurants espouse is the human touch
for me the ultimate luxury is not the
lack of humans it's that there are
humans there and that they're touching
it with their personal potential for
error and their humaneness is what makes
something for me really delicious and
that interchange is super significant to
my style of restaurant that doesn't mean
that that's not going to be somewhere
else and I mean in a world where
Chipotle can go further and further and
further you don't necessarily need a
human relationship with a delicious well
sourced great idea to bring you that
food in a very quick time but in terms
of the kind of restaurant experience
that I have spent a lot of my time
developing and working on I don't see me
getting rid of human beings too quickly
up next rule number six intersect art
and commerce as a core of your business
ideology
to figure out what it is that you can
make that is perceived as value as
delicious and as something you want to
make when I talk to all of my chef
friends what's important for all of us
is to realize we need to live on the
intersection of art the food we want to
make and commerce the food they want to
eat and if you can find that in the same
vicinity then you have a restaurant idea
if you just want to make stuff that
makes you completely happy and your
customers don't understand it you do not
have a business you have a good place
for you to express your art but the most
important thing is that it's a
sustainable experience for both you your
staff and your customers let's go to
rule number seven fall forward
you have so many success in your life is
it any failure that you're going to
listen from failures a word though that
doesn't really enter into my vocabulary
there are things that are less
successful I like that when you fall
forward on your face you are moving
forward like cooking like anything as
well stated by Gladwell in his outliers
it takes years of practice to make it
look effortless when you watch an
Italian do a kiss kiss and throw their
coat over their shoulder like that it
took them ten hundred thousand million
drives at the house to throw it over
just like that
now they're badass they're kissing
someone at the train station it took
practice to get there it's time for rule
number eight set your team up for
success it's part of being a good
businessman to both understand the
business of the kitchen the business of
the front of the house and the success
of your employees being integral to the
success of your operation even after
they leave you I support a lot of my
team as they go on beyond my restaurant
business I'm far more satisfied by their
success having already had luck to see a
dishwasher become a line cook become a
manager become an executive chef open
their own restaurant and and have it be
successful is probably to my taste the
most delicious thing I can have happen
to me now let's go to rule number nine
have family meals as someone who's
worked in restaurants and also
experienced eating at home for dinner
with your family where do you see the
future of that going because more and
more families don't eat dinner together
and more and more restaurants don't cook
for their employees it's a good one well
the good thing is pardon me I'm a little
wheezy right now take a little LSD I'll
be just fine um well I mean the future
of the whole meal is obviously in your
hands and I would suggest two things
cook more often cook more simply make
the meal required and most significantly
when you finish the meal let the dirty
plates sit on the table for 20 minutes
because it sets the tone for the
conversation if every single part of
your day is doing something and you need
to get it done and then the next step is
doing something else put your phones in
a stack they're calling I don't know why
they keep pulling you I don't know it's
cuz too many people have my damn phone
number
Hey put your phones in ask at and at the
end of the meal don't make the move that
everyone sit and understand that we're
gonna sit here for 20 or 30 minutes and
just chat you can't do anything but chat
you can't clear because that sets the
tone for the conversation that can
happen and should happen if you have
kids that sets them up for understanding
that this is crucial indictable time if
it's your roommates you should all agree
to it at least once or twice a week in
college we're gonna sit here and talk
for 20 minutes with their dirty plates
in front of us because it sets a tone
for the rest of our life if every single
moment has to be moving forward we're
never gonna find time to
relax we're never going to get to know
each other and we're never going to be
able to relax and kind of meditate on
the meal and the beginning of digestion
and the beginning of our conversation
and knowing each other my restaurants
will always have a family meal no matter
what the rule is no matter whether we
get a meal credit or whether anyone gets
it take a meal credit it is crucial time
and it's also at that time we have a
rule that after everyone's done eating
and we're still talking about wine or
we're talking about service tonight 10
minutes
you do not clear the table because if
every time you're doing something you're
always moving forward and you're always
moving on to your next project and
you're always look at your phone you're
trying to figure out who's snapchatting
who or what's the next Twitter thing is
you're we're losing perspective on it
and we it could be argued that we lost
it but if you slowly start taking back
quiet personal time and that's involving
food to start but then I would suggest
that you grab personal time in the day
time start meditating take 20 minutes
twice a day take 20 minutes to reflect
on something just take 20 minutes to
look at a building from outside and
don't say anything to anybody try to
find 20 or 10 minutes lots 5 or 6 times
a day you will feel better about life
and you will reflect that on every
conversation that you have you will be a
better person and will be better people
and finally rule number 10 before we get
to the bonuses master your craft today
I'm going to show you how to make pizza
if you follow these instructions anybody
can make this with you and cook like a
pro Pizza is the single most
recognizable food on the planet what it
really comes down to is that pizza is
simple it's easy to make it shouldn't be
too complicated two of my favorite
pizzas are Audiology a peperoncino and
marguerite let's get started with the
dough so I have three and a half cups of
flour I'm going to take in the very
middle of that about a cup and a quarter
of blood temperature water that's to say
somewhere between 96 and 98 point 6 then
I'm gonna take my yeast
and I'm gonna mix that in that is one
package of active dry yeast I want to
start that with about a tablespoon and a
half of sugar allow it to just sit there
for a second I'm gonna add about a
quarter cup of extra virgin olive oil
after about thirty seconds you'll see
that the yeast starts to bubble up
that's the key once that happens I stir
it all in when you really get down to it
what you're gonna use is your hands
we're gonna need this until it comes
together I'm gonna add about two
teaspoons of salt maybe a tablespoon a
little salty doesn't hurt because I'm
really looking for this to have its own
flavor
I'm getting a massive upper-body workout
right now you can't measure this you
can't do this in the gym and it really
doesn't make a difference when you get
to the point where it feels almost like
it's just about to firm like it's not
really giving anymore when you do the
need like so then you're done and now
this at this point you're ready to let
the pizza rise take this just like so
and put it in a warm place that's
somewhere in your kitchen we allowed to
really almost triple in volume so after
you allow to rest for about 45 minutes
we're gonna do is we're gonna cut them
like that everything about this is easy
the pro tip here is to make sure that
you don't tear you don't want to stretch
it too thin although it's a little Guido
throwing pizza actually gives you the
best way of extending that without
pushing your fingers through it so
that's the reason it exists but the real
trick is going to be when I show you
that you use your stove sipar bake
across in advance I have my heat on
medium high
you could drop it on like that and then
by the time we get to the final product
what you're gonna see is it's got a
better crust it's got a better chew and
in fact it's a better pizza let's make
the very first pizza a pizza margherita
and that's fresh mozzarella tomato and
basil I'm gonna take about that much
sauce and we're gonna go starting in the
center and this is where my kids get a
little jiggy they like to have fun
retaining they're going to use a
paintbrush they've decided to make it
into a Picasso or something like that
but in my opinion the trick is don't
overdress it and I mean come on you guys
the trick is not putting too much
mozzarella the whole idea of extra
cheese pizza no boar no male so this
goes right into the brother right on
this pan just like so
now unfortunately there are no pro tips
and knowing exactly what it's gonna be
duck you're gonna see the cheese is
melted and the crust will get a kind of
a little char on it I'm gonna say this
piece is done and now let's get started
with the value O'Leary peperoncino Pizza
what it has is merely garlic and the
garlic oil a little secret in the
restaurant world is poaching your
toppings in the oil what you get is the
two things you get first of all the
ingredient itself but then you get the
fragrant oil that has all the heady
deliciousness of anything you have to
cook in it I take garlic sliced paper
thin I put it in a pan with olive oil i
submerge it underneath the olive oil I
bring it up slowly
it gives me these beautifully poached
garlic cloves it's twice as unctuous and
second of all the oil that's left over
has the Magnificent fragrance of
whatever you've just cooked in it that's
one of the greatest tricks of all time
I've done the same thing with these
Fresno chilies and then we take this one
chili up now the broilers on kill the
phasers are run stun put that in like
that if you've ever had a pizza fail it
probably wasn't actually failing you
were probably impatient what you have to
do is burn two pizzas to understand
where the wall of acceptable variation
in color is
so now the pizza will always get a
little herbs at the last second so I'm
tearing them I'm not chopping them you
never seen an Italian Rama chopping
stuff on a board everything that really
happens in the Italian kitchen happens
over the food in your hands very last
second another drizzle like that and
there you have Mario Batali's crispy
pizza
thank you guys so much for watching my
personal favorite rule I think I'm gonna
go with number five create great
experiences it's something that I'm
trying to do in all of my businesses at
Toronto dance salsa we're looking at how
can we make the best possible experience
for people who are coming in to take
dance classes with us not just teaching
them the moves we're giving them an
emotional experience same thing for my
youtube channel for my website
everything that you guys are consuming
here I want it to be not just knowledge
that you're feeding into your head but a
fantastic experience for you along the
way I don't always make it perfect I
make a ton of mistakes along the way but
that's my goal and so it's a constant
reminder to myself to create great
experiences as well so I appreciate that
message from Mario I'd love to know from
you is rule number five crate great
experience is your personal favorite or
is there another rule that you like
better let me know leave it down the
comments below I'm really curious to see
what you have to say now I made this
video because April blitz asked me to if
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next check out the
link in the description you can go to
the request line and cast your vote I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Roger Pierce from Pierce words comm
Roger thank you so much for picking up a
copy of my new book the top ten roses
success and taking that awesome picture
in front of the Christmas tree
I love the smile thank you so much for
the support man I really really really
appreciate it so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon what inspires your cooking
and are there times when you just don't
want to cook I was originally inspired
by the fact that my family always cooked
we grew up in Washington State we were a
second-generation immigration family for
both french-canadian and Italian we
always cooked we that was what we did
like for us a good time on New Year's
Day was to make 400 pounds of sausage
for the year that was a Lulu when it was
blackberry season we would take our
yellow cutlass supreme station wagon
down to dash Point Road in Federal Way
and pick blackberries until we could no
longer see each other because we had
black berry fights during the blackberry
picking session and we would come back
and make enough jam and enough pies to
last us for a year so for us cooking was
foraging foraging was fun
was something that we did it was kind of
a chore thing but it was also just one
of the things that we did so cooking was
always something that I enjoyed and I
loved and as a matter of fact when my
mom suggested that I go to cooking
school instead of university when I was
a sophomore in high school I had just
seen Animal House and there was no way I
was going to miss out on this whole idea
of college in retrospect I would suggest
to anybody that if they want to get a
job in any craft whether it's cooking or
arc welding or or anything you should go
to a liberal arts college and learn
something about the world become
fascinating and become fascinated and
then go off and learn your handcraft and
become something else
but don't just go to a trade school
first and that's it because you won't be
as good a business person you won't be
as interesting you won't have as many
opportunities and that's why you're all
here anyway
so over the years I want to cook every
day of my life you know in the last two
weeks everyone's saying crops are cool
and I think it's Alan [ __ ] that made
them cool I just kept staying on and
staying on and staying on you got a
Batman button you've got a skull and
crossbones button on there they're
pretty cool that that's Batman is
because Adam West who was the original
Batman in the TV show and I share a
birthday and that's not skull and
crossbones that's Keith Richards that's
Keith oh okay go on sorry with your
question tell me how did you develop
your signature style and the confidence
to wear it it's just something like I am
obviously not I mean it's it's a look I
don't know that that it's a fashion
statement it's just like at a certain
point in your life you realize I don't
really care what people think about my
clothes and when when Clinton Kelly
who's a famous fashion plane who worked
with us on the chew is as proud of my
look because he says you wear it and you
do it I don't spend any time in my day
thinking about what clothes I'm gonna
put on like I don't spend even one
minute I grab the first thing in the row
of shirts the first thing in the row of
shorts and I wear the same shoes every
day so imagine all the free time that a
lot of other people spend thinking about
what they're gonna wear that I can
devote to doing whatever else I want
other famous people like famous for good
reason not famous
cooking like Albert Einstein has Steve
Jobs they always wore the same clothes
so I'm in a long line of those kind of
guys for anybody interested in any level
on any part of any art the most
important category to get together first
is your person you must learn to be
comfortable in your skin you must learn
to have a critical mind you must learn
to be thirsty and hungry for knowledge
at the same time you must read and once
you've got to that point then you should
learn your craft and if it's gonna be
cooking I suggest that you go to the
best restaurant you know and work for
free for a year that's the way to learn
cook eat schools are all great but if
you really want to learn what's going on
and how to be a restaurateur you should
go work in a restaurant if you want to
learn how to be a cooking teacher you
should go to a cooking school you want
to hear how to make wine you should go
to a winery then learn how to make Ford
you should go to Detroit all of the
things that you could possibly learn you
should go to the place where you think
they make the best one and work there
for free because it's the only and most
efficient way to get all of that
information the most important work ever
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you that sums you
Apple that would be like a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details